es war der korona hotspot die
österreichische ski und apres ski
hauptstadt ischgl jeder der sich hier im
märz aufhielt musste sich testen lassen
und jetzt liegen die ergebnisse vor
einer der wichtigsten corona
massenstudien das wichtigste ergebnis
fast jeder zweite bewohner hat
inzwischen antikörper gegen den corona
virus gebildet 42,4 prozent so ein hoher
grad an durchseuchung wurde weltweit
nirgendwo anders nachgewiesen
85 prozent der infizierten hätten ihre
infektionen nicht einmal bemerkt für sie
also war corona komplett harmlos
rückblick im märz kalt ist noch als
gefährlichster ort europas
laut österreichischer behörden waren 40
prozent der infektionen in ganz
österreich auf ich will zurück zu führen
dann stellten sich 1473 personen aus 479
haushalten der untersuchung mit dem
spektakulären ergebnis der innsbrucker
forscher und ist ist will nun damit
immun gegen korona das sei noch nicht
erwiesen sagen die mediziner
man gehe aber weiter davon aus dass
gehalte nicht mehr an corona erkranken
könnten